welcome to Wall Street the epicenter of
financial power in America perhaps the
money capital of the world
the globally oriented Financial firms
based here in the New York Stock
Exchange that operates here have
extraordinary influence on the politics
and policies of this country
no one has elected them and in fact
these Financial firms are trying to undo
the regulations and new laws governing
them imposed by the Congress
the people on Wall Street are just one
of a number of unelected and very
powerful forces that operate in the
shadows behind the scenes they're the
media of forces they're the military and
Industrial forces they're the corporate
forces and they're the forces that we'll
be investigating in this television
series which asks a question that most
of our media does not who rules America
every four years Americans go to the
polls to elect a president
it's a ritual that goes back to the
founding of the nation in 1776.
our economy seemingly on the brink of
class high unemployment every four years
politics and politicians dominate our
television screens dominate our news and
dominate our national discourse
[Music]
Ron Paul when I approved this message
what independent Watchdogs called this
president President Barack Obama is
running for reelection Mitt Romney stood
with big oil for their tax breaks
attacking higher mileage standards and
Renewables he is attacking and being
attacked by Republicans
he said he would turn this economy
around in three years or he'd be looking
at a one-term proposition we're here to
collect all right
the two parties may be fighting a
political war but pundits labeled it a
horse race fueled literally by billions
of dollars in campaign contributions
used for pervasive advertising where one
president's failed policies
at home
[Music]
welcome to obamaville the focus is on
political personalities not the forces
they represent a large industry of
commentators and pollsters are paid to
tell us who's ahead and who's behind
the focus invariably is on the
candidates not the issues but everyone
knows the campaigns are run behind the
scenes by professional strategists media
experts and political advisors
the political ads are cynical and slick
almost every word is scripted symbols
Trump's substance slogans are Market
tested aimed at promoting perception and
reinforcing prejudices that are world
nation marketing is the mission selling
is not telling
on one level this whole spectacle is
presented as a Triumph of democracy as
if the candidate who wins will run the
country but being in office doesn't
necessarily mean being in power
Americans believe they are determining
their future are they do most know or
are they ever told who rules America I
just think that these people uh you
can't really see them yeah that's what I
think the people who rule America people
are behind the screen they are behind
screen invisible
to the General Public
we know what's going on
[Applause]
to some extent yes and to some extent no
to what extent yes to what extent no
about 50 50.
who rules America there's no one right
answer Pulitzer prize-winning American
historian Eric foner says it's a
question that raises many more questions
about power that works from the Shadows
who rules America uh you know there's no
one single easily defined group who
rules America but I think you know not
just now but I think for a couple of
generations we have had a what what the
sociologists see Wright Mills called in
the 1950s a power elite an interlocking
set of connections of people in business
in politics in the military who
pretty much determine the parameters of
possible change it's not that they rule
American a conspiratorial way and of
course there are elected officials but
the leeway of those officials is
constrained by what you might call the
permanent government presidents come and
go but there's a kind of permanent
establishment what you know President
Eisenhower called the military
industrial complex but now it's more a
military Financial complex
that really you know determine as I say
determines the limit
foreign
Forum a gathering of progressive
intellectuals and Scholars and students
held every year here in New York City
there are 1400 speakers this year they
don't agree on everything but they do
agree that America is not the Democracy
it claims to be they all want to know
who rules America Professor Stanley
iranowicz writes about the research of
this man C Wright Mills who a half
century ago wrote about the existence of
a power elite that activists today refer
to as the one percent the people who run
things his contribution to understanding
the nature of power in America is in the
first place to identify three
institutional orders that really
together form the power elite an elite
that is generally speaking unresponsive
to the people unresponsive to democratic
Liberties and Democratic procedures and
he said the three groups were the
corporate capitalist uh institutions the
military and the third one was the top
layer of the political uh directorate he
called them and they were they are the
national uh leaders like the executive
branch of government not even Congress
he said Congress was in the middle
levels of power it doesn't really share
the decision to make war the major
economic policies and so on it
participates at some level but basically
it's out of power and he said that
really has undercut
the whole pretense of progressive and of
representative government
this may be why in recent surveys only
seven to nine percent of the American
people in both parties believe that the
Congress the so-called people's house of
government is representative and capable
of solving the country's problems
if politicians are trapped in a
polarized and highly partisan stalemate
who does exercise the power to decide
what the country's priorities and
policies should be
we asked JK Fowler an editor of the
mantle a political magazine I think it's
extremely complicated I think there's
not one particular answer for it I think
that a lot of the
stuff going on in America right now is
being led by money and money venture
but I think there's a bubbling movement
from the ground up as well that's
happening is there a ruling class in
America or is that a an outdated concept
oh I'm a strong believer that there's a
there's a Class A particular in
particular in New York City where but I
don't think it's they're not hidden
array in some room with precarious deeds
in mind it's it's more
it's more structural there's certain
clubs they go to there's certain streets
they live on they're interacting with
one another more we put that question to
Aaron crowl a 30 year old working-class
mother from a small town in Wisconsin
who was working two jobs while pursuing
her education
if I was to ask you like who runs
America who rules America what what is
your you know what what is your
perception of that
people that have the money to do so you
know
um you know people that that that have
the money and the the resources to send
a lobbyist to Washington you know like
nobody from my town could afford to send
a lobbyist you know and say hey Harley
Davidson is you know threatening to to
move their plants to China unless you
know everybody takes pay cuts
you know and could literally shut our
town down you know we can't afford to
defend ourselves
do you feel
as an American citizen that you have
power you know in our country do you
feel as if you have the ability to get
your
dream achieved
I feel like it's slipping away
um
I don't think I do you know because it
feels like the closer and closer I would
get to that you know like just a dream
for me is to finish college you know and
take care of myself and take care of my
son you know but
even that now you know and and I
understand like
most a lot of people in my position
aren't even able to get that far now
so if the citizens who are supposed to
be in charge don't feel they are who
does what we found is that by and large
it's the wealthiest Americans who call
the shots through unelected institutions
that drive agendas in their own
interests
there may be a cabal running things but
in the end the state and the system
merges argues Canadian political analyst
Leo panich
I don't think there's an external Force
controlling the American state the
American state is capitalist to its core
and the Very way it's organized it
doesn't do it because there's too much
influence from Wall Street it does it
because it is structurally embedded with
Wall Street it doesn't do it because
there's too much influence from a
military-industrial complex it doesn't
because the military-industrial complex
is inside this thing is funded by the
state is part of the state sure they're
people who conspire and there's people
who act in secret but capitalism is not
a conspiracy the people who have the
wealth they're not a conspiracy we know
who they are we know how they collect
this money they take it out of our
pocket they put it in theirs and it's
not a big mystery there seems to be
corporate forces in addition to Wall
Street that essentially help guide our
political and economic Direction
leading our America's top corporations
political analyst Michael Claire has
studied the political economy of oil for
20 years and says a lack of media
coverage keeps the public in the dark
does the media cover it the media
doesn't cover this for the most part in
fact the media is largely in League
because of the advertising dollars that
the oil and gas Lobby provides they're
very heavily dependent on Advertising
Revenue so they're very careful in what
they say who are they accountable to are
their laws really controlling and
regulating what they do
there are laws but they have been
written largely by their lobbyists to
favor them so in fact the laws for the
most part are in their favor not in the
favor of most Americans is there an
issue where we've seen this very clearly
where the interests of the oil industry
or the or the energy industry is in
conflict with the interests of Americans
well I would give an example that uh the
oil industry has been pushing for
drilling in the Deep Waters of the Gulf
of Mexico and off the coast of Alaska
for example and they get all kinds of
tax benefits for that kind of Deep Water
Drilling and they were able to do so
during the bush period with absolutely
no oversight whatsoever hence the deep
water Horizon disaster
most Americans experience the oil
industry in two places at the gas pump
where prices often rise because of
speculation not just supply and demand
and also through TV advertising that
paints this very profitable business in
the most positive of terms I'm still
here and so is BP we're committed to the
goal for everyone who loves it and
everyone who calls it home that's good
for our country's energy security and
our economy
[Music]
which brings us to another set of
Corporations the media companies
Jeff Cohen has been in the media and
written books about its impact in
shaping how Americans think about their
country and its system of power he says
media companies push propaganda for war
it's the same exact media
quoting the same exact experts that
pushed our country and the world into a
war with Iraq and we were told by these
media oh we're so sorry we didn't know
you know we made a mistake next time
we'll be more Vigilant but here we are
next time ten years later and the same
media are blowing smoke about a weapons
program in Iran that doesn't exist there
was no weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq either and so we're hearing uh it's
it's like you know when the war drums
are beating and I worked in mainstream
television news in this country during
the run-up to the Iraq War when the war
drums are beating they don't let you put
on opposing views we try to get opposing
views that question the evidence the
intelligence that would justify an
attack on Iraq but we were kicked off
the air and now you're finding it's it's
a nightmare it's a nightmare that's
happening again at the same time Jeff
most people who work in major media and
I of course did as well don't believe
this they don't buy this they feel like
they do have the freedom to cover issues
and that the networks are much more
diverse in their point of view than
Outsiders like you and maybe now me
would say well the the way to rebut that
fiction is just to look at what happened
in the wake of the Iraq invasion those
of us who question the evidence that
they were a weapons of mass destruction
threat we were totally right and most of
us got kicked out of the TV networks the
people who got it wrong have promoted up
so this idea of diversity in the
mainstream Media or good journalism will
win out certainly hasn't been proven in
the last 10 years where the the
journalists who got it right have been
punished sanctioned or kicked out of the
media and the journalists who got it
wrong most of them have more power today
to blow smoke in Iran than they had even
when they were blowing smoke at Iraq
those people the people who own
institutions are usually very conscious
of their power not just as individuals
but it's part of a dominant class says
independent TV producer Brian drolet so
there's a lot of talk here about
Democrats and Republicans who revote for
the Democrats we vote for the
Republicans there's a lot of talk about
you know the rich versus the 99 but it's
it's kind of you know the the there's a
certain kind of Amnesia about the
structure of our society that at one
point in this country at least had some
currency you know in the 30s and even in
the 60s you could talk about the working
class nobody talks about the working
class it's all about there's a middle
class and then there's the one percent
as if there's no and I guess then
there's some you know poor blacks and
Latinos or something right and I think
that that word has been sanitized and
scrubbed out of the vocabulary of the
people of the United States including
out of the vocabulary of the left now
that's not the entire left but even the
people that use the word class don't
seem to have the ability to to phrase it
in a way that actually means something
to people
to talk about classes not to talk about
a conspiracy but a complex system that's
evolved over the years A system that is
stratified and uses campaign
contributions and lobbying to ensure
that the politicians do the bidding of
the companies
so these are the building blocks of the
analysis we'll explore in this series on
who rules America
the argument is simple but hard for many
Americans to comprehend because many of
us want to believe the myths we learned
in school that make us feel Superior to
other countries and other peoples this
has been called American exceptionalism
many in America believe that God created
this country as the greatest country on
Earth and that's what makes it so
special so you really have to start with
that as a basis for how the United
States was founded Roxanne Dunbar Ortiz
is one leader of America's indigenous
people the first Americans they were the
ones to be eliminated yes because it was
their land that was wanted not even
their labor like in Latin America
yeah
the indigenous people were enslaved and
made into peasants
but in North America the Anglo
anglo-colonium was
the U.S New Zealand and Australia had
the motive effectively wiping them out
and taking their land so that it's not
just that they weren't included they
were to be eliminated
and so questions about the custodians of
real power and who rules America lead
back to debates on how to remake power
how to challenge its distribution and
make it more transparent and accountable
these are the issues that the Occupy
Wall Street movement is Raising as it
challenges institutional power in an
attempt to revive Grassroots democracy
David DeGraw explains occupies Origins
influence of events you know everything
's Direction you know I was I was
looking around the world you know it was
there's protests happening in Egypt and
then it moved to you know the Arab
Spring Tunisia and all throughout Europe
came back and it was just a matter of
time before it hit the United States and
really if you look the the occupations
globally you know they became like the
thing to do so it's just a natural
progression for it to show up here I
feel like it shows up here because you
know even though wealth is so
concentrated you know the people have a
media system where they're so
propagandized and they feel isolated but
you know occupy shows that people are
you know not suffering alone they're
coming out and raising awareness and we
changed the national discourse the
movement is up against powerful forces
with large budgets and the backing of
police forces and the political
establishment
while these activists are on the front
lines of the fight for a people-ruled
America many of its people share the
same hope
they're being like an upper class
working class absolutely absolutely
um
you know I I'm I'm a waitress at a very
nice restaurant and it's very clear to
me you know where what my role is and
who I am you know and you can tell just
just from the dialogue that I have with
people you know um
recently I had I talked to a general
manager of a fairly large business in
our town and
you know when when I mentioned that I
was going to a public school you know
I got kind of an eye roll and oh yeah my
tax dollars pay for that you know and
it's
you feel like there's all this
resentment against working people kind
of feeling like they don't deserve what
they're what little they're getting
absolutely absolutely and especially you
know with with the recent attacks on
public sector employees like on on
teachers and you know people are saying
you know they don't deserve those
benefits we all don't get those benefits
so so they don't deserve them either you
know or like why isn't the conversation
maybe we should all work to get those
for everyone instead of taking it away
from the few that do have them
you know when I hear you talking
uh you know I realized it's a such a
bigger picture here that most people
even understand that we have you know a
country where the dream is slipping away
for so many people uh and they don't
feel particularly powerful they don't
feel like they can do anything they can
achieve anything they can make a
difference
right well I think the dream is shifted
to uh hopefully I wake up tomorrow and
I'll be able to pay my rent and keep a
roof over my head you know or it's just
like
you know I'll I'll work on achieving my
dream tomorrow but today
you know I have to
have to go to class you know and I have
to you know I have to get my work done I
have to go to work and I have to try to
squeeze a couple hours of sleep in and
then you know and it's
now you're here at this conference with
all these brilliant
theoreticians and analysts and
professors and experts and leaders and
how do you feel about this this idea
that people have to get together to make
a difference
I think it's wonderful
I I'm
I feel so blessed to be able to be here
with people like that because I want to
learn you know somebody had you know had
said to me well why don't you leave
where you are and I don't think that's
the answer I think that it's my job as
somebody who cares about these things to
learn from these people to learn from
these Brilliant Minds and so I can take
this back to people and and and and show
them and explain to them where we don't
have access to this kind of thing every
day you know and
so hopefully try to Enlighten them a
little bit
Aaron expresses the hopes of many
ordinary Americans who want to reshape
the nature of power so that the 99 not
just the one percent can rule but as you
can see in here it's not a battle she
feels she is winning perhaps that's why
she like many want to know who rules
America
question of who rules America has been
debated throughout America's own history
it was originally raised and answered to
some degree by the American Revolution
in the 1770s that fought for
independence from the British crown so
that Americans at least some Americans
could rule themselves or at least they
hoped they could we're at Columbia
University with Dr Eric foner a
historian and writer and teacher here at
the University for a long long period of
time to own property I think what is
unusual today is two things one the
degree of inequality never before has
the very very top the one percent had so
much of the national income and wealth
in its own hands and uh you know so that
the Gap is greater than ever before and
secondly
um
you know Occupy Wall Street is not
primarily a movement of farmers of
laborers it doesn't have the same base
people need to learn history that's part
of our job to know that this issue has
been around for a long time there was
nothing Un-American about raising the
question of economic plutocracy economic
inequality it's as American as apple pie
and um you know I think that the Occupy
Wall Street people are
you know legitimate Heirs of a long and
venerable tradition in this country
today the activists of Occupy Wall
Street are continuing the fight for
independence and economic Justice from
Domination by a small Elite in the name
of the majority the 99 of America I do
think what's been brilliant about the
Occupy Wall Street movement is the
framing of the one percent versus 99 and
I think I think I think what we
basically have is an undemocratic power
structure that goes across political
economic social and cultural lines what
kind of impact has Occupy Wall Street
had in raising basic questions about the
nature of power in America we asked
sociologists Stanley iranowitz
it's had it has an impact on perception
it has changed the conversation
the question is whether or not it will
be able to change policy and the
argument that I would make is that it
should not worry about changing policy
in the short run the only way to change
policy in the long run is going to be to
create even a bigger movement and in
order to create that bigger movement
what it has to do is has to ask the
question what kind of a life do we want
to lead what is the good life what is a
vision of the way in which we want to
live David DeGraw coined the 99 one
percent phrase and was an early occupy
organizer
he explained why who rules America
remains an urgent issue
so you have big Banks and concentrated
wealth that's just rigged the political
process uh you know investigating it we
have a country where U.S millionaire
households have 46 trillion dollars of
wealth it's just a mind-boggling number
so you know over the past Generation all
the wealth has gone to the top you know
really it's one tenth of one percent
more than one percent but uh you know
breaking it down even further you have
400 people who have as much wealth as
155 million Americans so that's 400
people as much wealth as half the
population
the seeds of a battle that many of the
occupiers see as a new American
Revolution is not really new but deeply
rooted in the unresolved history of
conflict in the United States between
those who own and control its resources
and those who want economic equality
[Music]
the first thing you have to understand
is America is a business venture like
still a land still stolen property
capitalism and it's about making money
you know many revolutions start at the
top in other words the people who began
the struggle against Great Britain were
merchants in Boston and New York
plantation owners in Virginia you know
most of the founders in Virginia are
slave owners but what happens is as the
struggle intensifies they have to
generate support among Ordinary People
and when you do that you break open the
political system and you open the door
for very very different kinds of Demands
slaves start demanding their own Freedom
uh women and Native Americans start
demanding greater equality so what
happens at the beginning when a you know
a more privileged class begins the
resistance that doesn't necessarily tell
you how the whole process is going to
take place
this conflict between the one percent
actually the 0.001 and the 99 percent
had its Echoes here in the home of
America's anti-colonial Uprising in the
back streets of Boston where a freedom
trail today commemorates a massacre by
the British and a fight for liberty and
that's where we'll take you next
what's the American Revolution really a
revolution the British thought it was a
revolution no question about that it was
not a social upheaval in the way let us
say the French Revolution was but it's
certainly overthrew an entire system of
government it replaced the ruling class
with another one so that seems to be
What A revolution is about and it raised
these questions of equality in the
society not not just equality in terms
of one percent and 99 but the role of
slavery in American Life the status of
women in American life it Unleashed a
kind of um uh struggle for equality
among all sorts of groups which
continued long after the Revolution was
over
listen my children and you shall hear of
the midnight ride of Paul Revere that's
one of the most famous poems of the
American Revolution and here we are in
front of the Statue of Paul Revere the
man who alerted all of Massachusetts to
the British troops coming into their
communities we're on the Freedom Trail
in Boston where the American Revolution
is remembered well what kind of a
Revolution was it what actually happened
here in Boston back in the 1700s what
have we learned since then
thousands of tourists and students visit
these revolutionary monuments every day
but most have only a foggy idea of what
really happened and tend to repeat the
mythologies that are taught in their
schools here was Paul Revere Paul Revere
was one of the great revolutionary
Heroes so you kids here to see the
special reports can I ask you a question
about it sure we're doing a little TV
program here who was Paul Revere what
was this all about do you know he was a
founding time yeah midnight ride to
warned about the British for coming did
you know that he was a very rich
businessman a silversmith here in Boston
and that he wanted to be in the
Continental Army and they wouldn't let
him in did you know that I didn't know
that I know that did you know that in
Boston there was this Merchant class you
know Business Leaders the one percent
who were really running the whole show
uh in many ways and that the people were
not as involved because back then it was
slaves there were indentured servants uh
there were a lot of people who didn't
have a say in what was going on did you
know about that no idea I didn't know
anything about Paul revereign
okay I'm supposed to learn about it in
history my brother Bill here has taught
history uh to students in Massachusetts
for many many many years and has
followed you know the various debates
about our history what was it about this
revolution uh you know was it a popular
Uprising or was it sort of led by Elites
here in Boston well both were true there
were popular elements uh Ordinary People
did resent the British
Ordinary People did participate in riots
and boycotts uh but there was a one
percent back then
uh the leaders of the revolution
both leaded and channeled it they were
certainly not above using words like
Liberty and freedom uh to deflect and
distract people from their own
discontents in the colonies and their
own interests I mean the the business
class of Boston didn't want more taxes
on their products they wanted to compete
with the British goods they felt they
shouldn't be taxed and as a result there
was a t original tea party here in
Boston
and there were uh you know Merchants
like uh John Hancock who was into
smuggling goods and you're right they
didn't want to pay British taxes I mean
there were other factors behind the
revolution as well but when this
Revolution was codified in 1787 at the
Constitutional Convention the people who
were invited were the large landowners
the slave owners the merchant class no
women no Indians no blacks no working
people actually there were slaves that
were inspired by the revolution to try
to get their freedom some actually I
think the idea of the Revolution and the
idea of democracy uh were Radical
inspiring revolutionary in ways that
that actually might have made the
leaders uncomfortable since some of them
themselves owned slaves they they really
didn't want this to go viral in the way
it it did around the world so who ruled
America then in a way their
grandchildren are ruling it today and
sometimes direct descendants of those
people so uh you know I mean there was a
certain amount of class Mobility uh
indentured servitude disintegrated due
to the chaos of the Revolution but I
don't think the people who led the
revolution really intended a social
Revolution that was really not what they
were thinking about
After the Revolution people like Daniel
Shays in Western Massachusetts a farmer
a captain in the revolution uh did try
to
inspire organize another Rebellion
against those who he saw as replacing
his British Masters this time they were
the colonial leaders
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so here we are 225 years after the
Shay's Rebellion rocked Western
Massachusetts in a challenge to the one
percent of those times we have a
memorial for Daniel Shays and the men
who fought with him and what's
interesting is we have American flags
being put in a sense almost that his
Tombstone here marking support for the
values and the aspirations that he
fought for
my name is Dave wildstein you're at the
stagecoach Tavern in Western
Massachusetts town of Sheffield and this
painting is a painting of Daniel Shea's
militiamen Daniel Shay's fault in the
revolution they came back from the
Revolution and found
their Farms being foreclosed and many
put in prison because of the same debt
crisis that were
experiencing now there are many
similarities but essentially one of the
promises of the Revolution was to annul
the foreign debt and the farmers came
home and discovered the debt was even
greater and the banks were even tougher
today the Shay's Rebellion is mostly
forgotten but it lives on on YouTube
with songs and dramatic Recreations
she's now unsheathed his sword and
ordered the Fife and Drum players to
strike up a tune the men began Marching
In Cadence the irony says historian Eric
foner is that Shays was just a front man
for a mass movement
in fact it was the opponents who said it
Shea's rebellion in order to find the
kind of Boogeyman you know they could
attack so let's forget about Shay's as a
person and think about the mass movement
the farmers the ordinary laborers who
took to the streets shut down the courts
and said wait a minute we had a
revolution we have installed a
government that's supposed to represent
the people here in Massachusetts and yet
it's talking you know it's the bankers
and the landowners and the merchants who
are getting the benefit of everything
it was the first Occupy Wall Street
movement
they petitioned the government in Boston
for redress and the government ignored
the petitions and they're having still
had their arms they went to these Court
sites and picketed to prevent the courts
from sitting
succeeded to some extent until private
militias were formed and the
Massachusetts militias were formed to
suppress it
it was suppressed right near here right
last battle was fought in Sheffield it
was led by Brigadier Ashley who's the
Ashby house is still here and Colonel
Ashley his parents were one of the
heroes of the Revolution so here we have
the same family
of building Independence but then trying
to suppress it if many white Americans
were disappointed by the achievements of
the American Revolution what about
blacks and Native Americans
in 1730 when Sheffield was incorporated
there were 30 black families in
Sheffield half were slaves half were
free but the famous story is again at
the Ashley House one of the servants
Elizabeth Freeman called ma bets
overheard all the talk about the
Massachusetts Declaration of
Independence at the dining table and it
occurred to her that may she might
qualify and she actually filed in the
court of Great Barrington and won her
Freedom so here you have the court
giving freedom on one hand and
suppressing freedom on the other
years later a small black community in
the area that Daniel Shays made famous
became the home of a young man who had
become a leader of the fight for civil
rights he coupled concerns for racial
equality with demands for economic
Justice today in the center of his
hometown of Great Barrington
Massachusetts there's a wall mural
celebrating his political and
intellectual contributions it includes
quotes from president Barack Obama and
Martin Luther King Dr W.E.B Du Bois
Du Bois was one of the Titan Giants of
the 20th century of course he's born in
the 19th century Du Bois put forward the
issues which are still with us the race
issue in America you know he said 1903
the problem of the 20th century is the
problem of the color line it's still a
problem in this country and around the
world Du Bois talked about economic
equality and how to gain that and he
grappled with these questions he's a
brilliant writer a brilliant thinker and
much of what he said is still relevant I
think to thinking about American society
what about Native Americans they were
the ones uh to be eliminated yes because
it was their land
not even their labor Roxanne Dunbar
Ortiz is part of America's indigenous
movements and says the people we call
Indians were being exterminated we asked
her about the American Revolution it
wasn't a revolution it was a war of
independence from you know the colonial
over the power but it wasn't an
anti-colonial Revolution like the
bolivarian Revolutions in South America
or the Haitian revolution
so there are many different even
competing narratives about the origins
of the United States the United States
of course was founded as a settler State
as a Colonial
power
and the democracy has always been an
oligarchy
you know capitalist democracy with a
rhetoric above
populism which is so strongly based on
race that is if you're not if you're not
black if you're not a slave you're not
indigenous if you're white and a settler
then everyone could be a king everyone
can own land and be a landlord so all
these peasants who came as settlers the
dream is to be you know be the king of
the hills and so it's a very
um
very Insidious kind of democracy because
it's a it's a an illusion
illusion or not this is a subject that
needs to be examined if we are to
understand who rules America the origins
of the one percent and then teach about
it
so this is all part of the history that
most Americans probably don't know did
you find when you were teaching students
here that many of them just didn't know
much about their own history I think
there are many students that I taught
in one of the towns that fought at
Concord who were never even in the spot
we're standing in there I think that
that's true that that many kids were not
familiar with that is
Beyond local battlefields Beyond being
about the Revolutionary War which is
relevant to today because we live in a
globalized world is that this revolution
started locally here in Boston but soon
the British were involved the Dutch the
French it became a war of many different
countries all fighting on American soil
well very true and the the French
intervention was was very critical to
Our Success it wasn't all through the
force and Valor of our eyes
uh there were other people involved but
I think the you know the idea itself has
played a revolutionary role in history
but the idea itself did not create a
deep social revolution in the United
States and to this day people are
distracted by
um words like Liberty and freedom and
Justice uh in the same way that they
were back then
ironically the original tea party which
inspired the modern right-wing Tea Party
Movement today was actually a protest
against an earlier form of corporate
imperialism why was T the issue not corn
or whiskey or something like that it was
because the East India Company had gone
bankrupt in China
and the crown the British crown bailed
them out
so they wouldn't you know lose their
lose their assets but then the crown
looked around said well what does the
company have that we can sell well it
turned out what they had was T so they
decided to market the T and that's why
it was tea that was uh the tax issue
so here you have a big Financial failure
and the it was Global the the uh the
implications trip rippled across the
Pacific rippled across the Atlantic and
we have the Boston Tea Party
throughout our history there have been
sort of conspiracy theories about all of
this I mean today for example both the
right and the left seems to see the
Federal Reserve Bank as sort of a a
conspiracy concocted in 1913 without any
proper process and kind of running the
show yeah well you know conspiracy
theories conspiracy thinking is deeply
embedded in our political culture my PhD
supervisor my mentor Richard hofstetter
wrote the famous book in the 1960s the
paranoid Style in American politics in
which he traced out various kinds of
conspiratorial thinking whether it was
Catholics or in the before the Civil War
trying to undermine America or uh you
know various other groups at various
times immigrants others trying to you
know destroy the American culture or the
trilateral commission remember them in
the 1970s was supposedly ruling the
whole world now the Federal Reserve
right if we only abolish the Federal
Reserve Bank everything would go back to
some Utopia of the past
throughout U.S history you see various
right-wing movements point out
scapegoats in the society and they're
usually the the folks who are already
marginalized in some way or another and
and what happens is that there comes a
moment when it becomes really useful for
the elite Powers whether they're in
government or corporations to encourage
these movements so you get a tea party
or you get a militia movement like in
the 90s or you get the Ku Klux Klan in
the 1800s and what this is all about is
taking angry mostly white people who are
mostly somewhat privileged and
convincing them that they're about to
fall down the social economic ladder I
guess the basic problem with conspiracy
theories is that no group can fully
determine what happens even people with
great power launch things and then they
kind of lose control of them and things
happen in a way that is unpredictable
when you look back at history and and
you maybe can see because of you know
it's a long time ago all of these forces
yet today somehow in the news we never
see these forces what we see are
politicians spouting various you know
rhetoric and speeches but we don't
really know whose interests they're
serving who's behind the scenes well
this is why we need research we need uh
we need an understanding of who rules
America
because the mythology today is that it
is the people who rule America and most
folks don't know a great deal in terms
of specifics about the role that
corporations play
um the way politicians are tied to
corporate interests
change is possible I think when one
talks about who rules America and a
power elite one should not use that to
Simply fall into a kind of quietism and
say well nothing is possible no change
is possible everything's under control
many of the major popular movements in
our history have been big surprises you
know nobody expected them to come and I
think the same thing with Occupy Wall
Street nobody expected Occupy Wall
Street to come up similarly simply out
of nowhere and so I think you know we
have seen that over and over again in
our history and we will continue to
people say the one percent you know we
are the 99
but you know when I broke down the
numbers it was really it is a couple
hundred people in this country that have
immense wealth if you look at the if you
look at our election process it's
something like uh you know 100th or one
percent accounts for something like 80
percent of the campaign Finance I mean
that's Insanity I mean it's completely
it's a rigged game
and now the ball of History has been
passed to a new generation fighting to
transform a large and complex country
with many power centers but just as in
the past it has determined minorities
who make the difference and Elite made
the American Revolution and as we will
see a power elite still rules
[Music]
when retired World War II General Dwight
David Eisenhower ran for president he
was hailed as a military Savior and
All-American hero from The Plains of
Kansas
[Music]
now is the time for all good Americans
to come to the aid of their country vote
for Eisenhower no one expected that in
his farewell address he would identify
and oppose the emergence of a new power
constellation the military industrial
complex
in the councils of government we must
guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military industrial
complex
the potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist
we must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
Democratic processes
this was a prophetic speech especially
for a military leader who saw that a
fusion of government and corporate power
could lead to what he called unwarranted
influence and misplaced power
50 years later on the warnings
anniversary President Eisenhower's own
granddaughter Susan documented how the
military industrial complex had grown
she wrote in less than 10 years our
military and security expenditures have
increased by 119 percent
this new book on the cloud of the
military industrial complex by William
Hartung details the power it wields he
told me how it works
military contractors uniform military
the Pentagon basically pushing their
interest at the expense of taxpayer
National Security uh in case some cases
their civil liberties is it a
description of an actual reality
well the military industrial complex is
probably more real now than it was when
Eisenhower coined the phrase a company
like Lockheed Martin not only are they
building missiles they're building
cluster bombs they're building uh you
know submarines at the same time uh
they're helping process your taxes
they're counting the census they're
running fingerprint databases for the
FBI so it's kind of more from just the
military industrial complex to sort of
the National Security State so you've
got surveillance as well as Weapons
building
Hartung says these companies in effect
dictate our foreign policy they've sort
of captured our foreign policy and
captured our military policy really for
special interest purposes to large
degree
writer David Swanson believes that this
military-industrial complex relies on
Wars or the threat of Wars to stay in
business
Eisenhower pushed War propaganda in the
very same speech and throughout his
career but he could not have been more
right I think he he probably did not
imagine how huge the problem of what he
called the military-industrial complex
would become it I describe it as a
banker bailout every year it is a
trillion dollars over a trillion dollars
every year into the Machinery of mass
murder it is over half of federal
discretionary spending from the U.S
government it is as much and more than
all other nations of the world put into
the military each year it is much of it
unaccountable the the Pentagon routinely
loses quantities of money that are as
much as most other governmental
departments get
it's not just that more money is being
spent on arms but the rise of the
military industrial complex has been
accompanied by an overall rise in
corporate power and not just in the
military sphere
military contractors now have
disproportionate influence says Sheila
krumholtz of the center for responsive
politics there is a huge sum of money
coming from defense contractors in
particular and these range from a t and
Boeing the largest multinational kind of
Goliath their primary source of Revenue
may be telecommunications or or
Transportation but they have huge
contracts worth a ton of money with the
dod and and Military
there have been a number of uh pieces of
legislation aimed at both making that
connection more transparent and trying
to put a lid on the kind of pay to play
uh method that has ruled for instance
earmarks
have we seen a pattern of military and
Industrial occlusion and and Industrial
you know companies that do business with
the Pentagon giving more and more money
to politicians many defense contractors
were making contributions spending lots
of money to the lobby and and in
exchange winning uh contracts that maybe
they weren't the best
organizations to uh to benefit from so
there has been a lot of research done
about about how money uh greases the
skids for defense contractors I'll also
say that the revolving door plays an
important role so it's not just money
it's other forms of elite influence
where people in in the Department of
Defense are kind of lining up their next
their jump to the Private Industry where
they can rake in uh huge sums of money
and lucrative posts from in Private
Industry that they used to regulate
alongside the military are huge
intelligence agencies with vast budgets
to spy run covert action operations
collect personal data and conceal how
powerful interests operate today the
former head of CIA runs the Pentagon and
was replaced by a general the head of
the Navy Seals runs the Central Command
secrecy is pervasive in a National
Security State even as groups like
Wikileaks try to disseminate hidden
information
Wikileaks your baby has um in the last
few years has released more classified
documents than the rest of the world's
media combined can that possibly be true
yeah can it possibly be true it's a
worry isn't it that the rest of the
world's media is doing such a bad job
that a little group of activists is able
to release more of that type of
information than the rest of the world
press combined
years earlier an auto executive turned
defense secretary Charles Wilson said
what's good for General Motors is good
for America he saw no distinction
between an elected government and an
unelected Corporation
GM was a car company that became a major
defense supplier Boyd my military
spending and then years later became a
mortgage lender driven by Wall Street
originated and often fraudulent subprime
loans until it nearly collapsed and had
to be bailed out by government
the United States Supreme Court in its
citizens united decision has decided
that corporations like GM have the
rights of ordinary people and can openly
and sometimes secretly Lobby Congress
and the public or Finance political
campaigns to promote their agendas
there are now many criticisms against
citizens united many of the arguments
can be seen in this video by the story
of stuff campaign we have a democracy in
crisis
85 percent of Americans feel that
corporations have too much power in our
democracy and people have too little 85
percent hey that's a majority
so let's get together and take our
democracy back from the corporations
it's the first and most important step
in making real progress on all the
issues that people care most about
there is also a counter campaign
underway against corporate control of
politics focusing on two billionaire
political donors Charles and Edward Koch
two brothers both industrialists and
both funders of conservative campaigns
including one to suppress voting by
democrats
filmmaker Robert Greenwald has
distributed this video Nationwide
folks like the Koch brothers are
attempting to ensure that as few people
of color and as few young people show up
as possible we live we've undergone we
live in a corporate state
Chris Hedges is a best-selling author
and former reporter for the New York
Times the people who rule America are
the large corporate entities which are
supernational they have no loyalty to
the nation state they are harvesting the
country just like they're harvesting the
rest of the globe they're implanting a
global neofutalism where workers around
the planet have to be competitive which
means being competitive with Sweatshop
workers in Bangladesh who make 22 cents
an hour or prison labor in China it's
it's a global neofutalism
um it's one that
is
unassailable completely Untouchable and
more powerful than the host governments
that were there nominally based Hedges
is not alone in this view Professor
Michael Claire specializes in studying
the country's largest industry oil and
gas
I would say that the oil industry or
energy writ large coal natural gas
uranium is the most powerful Lobby in
America the most powerful economic
interest and it's tied to other powerful
interests automobile Highway
construction
Suburbia many other Industries tourism
are all linked to energy and they work
together to keep America addicted to oil
and to avoid the transition to
alternative fuels do they have an
influence on our politics do they have
an influence on what happens in
Washington what happens in the ballot
boxes of America they're the biggest
contributors to electoral campaigns in
general to the especially to the
Republican party and I think they have a
very powerful influence do you think
most Americans know how powerful they
are only the people who see this power
in their daily lives have grasped the
the strength of it for many Americans
the military-industrial complex is seen
only as a source of jobs and in fact
military contractors win political
support and federal funds by promising
to create jobs
there are real jobs people working in
the weapons factories and all the
subsidiary subcontractors but it's a
fraud because you could take those same
dollars and put it into any other
industry into infrastructure green
energy education or even into tax cuts
for working people and produce more jobs
than you do with the military spending
so it's worse than nothing purely on the
economic terms for years there have been
protests against America's Wars and the
military but most of targeted
politicians not necessarily the
corporations who profit from making
weapons and other products for the
military
[Music]
one of the groups that's most visible
and challenging militarism is a woman's
group code pink media Benjamin is a
co-founder
I've learned that we don't rule America
I've learned that the Democrats
don't rule Americans the corporations
rule America I've been doing the work on
the wars and I've just been floored of
how powerful these weapons manufacturers
are and how powerful the contractors are
and that they have the ability to kind
of keep the words going I mean that's
that's pretty amazing when you think
about it like I'm just doing a lot of
work around the drones issue do you know
there's a drones caucus in Congress I
mean instead of having a caucus to feed
preschool children you know they decided
it was more important to have a drone
caucus and that's because all the
manufacturers in their districts are
funding them they are quite open about
it and in fact over 50 members of
Congress have created a caucus for
drones where they openly promote the use
and sale of drones at home and abroad
and then they've now authorized the the
flight to at least 30 of up to 30 000
drones in U.S skies for whatever purpose
uh this this is in contrast to the lack
of any caucus for senior citizens for
children for health coverage for green
energy for for human beings there's a
caucus for robots
Eisenhower was so right and he was so
right when he said that it steals money
it robs us of food for our children of
health care for our parents who is so
right and it's just worse and worse and
you get the little puppets in Congress
and I live in Washington now so I see
these little puppets and wish that they
were like the NASCAR drivers that had to
have their corporations on their suits
but they don't rule America the
corporations obviously rule America and
when it comes to War and Peace those
corporations are so powerful that
they've kept us for the last decade
anymore and if we don't do something
about it they'll keep us at War for the
next decade
beyond the debates about the role of the
military there may be a deeper challenge
because the United States has evolved
from a nation into an Empire with a
far-flung system of bases economic
interests and intertangled business
dealings all around the world
top political leaders interact with
corporate leaders at meetings of Elites
like the Bilderberg conference the
trilateral commission and the
international monetary fund meetings
it's all part of a global structure of
corporate culture politics and Power
some like the billionaire George Soros
told me a while back that the world
economic forum is more like a networking
party than a decision-making venue
decisions are often made behind the
scenes not at public events
the divorce meeting is a
enormous sort of cocktail party a lot of
contacts people meet and so on a lot of
things are discussed it's actually very
convenient because you can meet a lot of
people whom you want to meet in in a con
confined period of time and it's also a
media event is it also a symbol of the
growth of sort of economic power of over
political power lack of sovereign loss
of sovereignty by some countries
well it is actually symptomatic of the
age because you have
presidents and prime ministers courting
the the the
financiers and the industrialists
only a few Americans seem to understand
how corporatization and globalization go
hand in hand Walter Teague was one of
the first activists against the Vietnam
War he believes that Americans can't see
the facts because they're trapped in
myths I asked them how he would explain
the situation to people on Mars
I'd have to explain some very crazy
things to them I'd have to explain it in
terms that they would perhaps understand
I'd have to not use some of the terms
that Americans commonly use because
if you use the language that we're
taught in school about democracy free uh
free will uh you know all of the how the
United States is number one Uber Alice
right
all those terms lead the person to not
being capable of understanding what
you're saying which is that there are
really and have been for a long time a
very small percentage one percent or
something like that
really make most of the decisions but
they are smart enough to make them in a
way that keeps most Americans until
recently from realizing that they're
being ruled we cannot undo the
plutocracy the kleptocracy the lack of
representation without dismantling the
military-industrial complex this is the
one percent of the one percent this is
where we give a banker bailout every
year and we don't get a dime of it back
we borrow it from China we pay it back
with interest we keep interest rates
ridiculously low we crash Wall Street we
bail it out because we've created a war
economy without any need for war well I
think if people had a better sense of
how these companies how the uniform
military how their allies in Congress
are basically running the show scaring
us into spending on weapons we don't
need I think they'd have the beginnings
of a tool to do something about it but I
think absent that information there's
sort of nowhere to start there's nowhere
to sort of plant your feet and try to
fight back against it so I'd have to
tell the Martians it's going to be very
hard for you to understand why Americans
don't see how they're being screwed they
don't see it except when it gets so bad
or so contradictory or so blatant or so
personal and then they wake up one day
and say oh my God does this mean in a
way that business that Wall Street that
defense contractors than others have
disproportionate power in other words
are they kind of one of the forces
ruling our country most people don't
even know about
I think that the money has great
influence across the board particularly
where the issues are Arcane and they
seem
disassociated with the average Americans
where constituents aren't paying
attention and they're not being heard by
their representatives in Washington I
think where people are paying attention
where it becomes a there is a hue and
cry from regular people it's hard for
the money to to beat out the marathon
policy politicians usually will not risk
the political liability of being seen as
catering to their the interest
bankrolling their campaign if the voters
are paying attention they're usually not
that that unwise
most of the public doesn't interface
with the military-industrial complex
because they participate in the economy
as consumers
but even there they're being affected by
a power shift an economic inequality
that drives them deeper and deeper into
debt George Scribner is an executive
with a corporation that advises other
corporations today it takes two hundred
thousand dollars a year to feel somewhat
affluent I asked George Scribner how he
thinks growing inequality is affecting
our politics who's in charge of our
country we keep reading more and more
about big money in politics there was a
great article of the one percent by the
one percent for the one percent and I
think it might have been Vanity Fair but
I'm not positive right now but they made
a point that I in politics that I've
been making in terms of business is that
for you know since World War II it was
head count that made a difference one
person one vote so you go you play to
the to the vote you know one person one
dollar you played to the as many people
as you could to get the dollars now
because the assets are concentrated at
the high end in the hands of the few
actually money is much more valuable
both the politicians and to marketers
than the mass of people that comprise
the middle class so it's a mass of
people being left out now the massive
Americans they certainly they aren't
being left out but they're certainly
less important
so I think in a variety of ways you'll
see them being less catered to and
manipulated more in a sense
and in politics and in terms of
marketing there'll be fewer products and
fewer Services that's one view from
inside the corporate world essentially
saying that the majority of Americans
have less economic power and as a result
less political power
people with money rule America because
people with money can acquire power
through that but we all have the great
thing about America is all we we all
live within the myth that each one of us
can make a difference and I think there
are enough opportunities for that to
happen that makes me think that the
future will be won't be as Bleak as it
seems sometimes
let's hope so certainly most Americans
believe their future is bright but given
the trends we've explored about who's in
power there certainly are doubts
especially because of the danger and
threat of new Wars that are being
planned secretly according to Professor
Stanley iranowitz
w war against Iran as a matter of fact
unless you refuse to count
um embargoes
um uh things like that are going on at
this very moment that is to say in March
of 2012. that's inactive that is
virtually an act of war that we are
saying to the Iranians either you bow to
our demand that you do not develop
nuclear weapons and you renounce nuclear
weapons or otherwise we will continue to
to Bar your goods from going back and
forth I mean after all the market is
part of the the system so they're saying
you have no Market rights so there is a
war underway right now I think so but
most Americans don't really know it do
they that's right they really know about
this power elite do they really know
about what she Wright Mills talked about
so many years ago why is that and how
can that change because we don't have a
left that really continually in an
effective way
talks about who has power in America we
have the Occupy Movement talked about 99
being deprived of uh economic uh Power
and about inequality but it is not even
close to being an analysis that can be
uh disseminated throughout the entire
Society we don't have it we don't have a
daily news system of daily newspapers we
don't have a weekly newspaper we have
Twitter we have you know uh various
other kinds of social media that we have
access to but it does not replace the
kind of systematic analysis that could
take place as a result of having our own
media so Americans in a way are still in
the dark and I think you know the left
forum and so many other efforts are
attempts to challenge that to change
them well yes that's right
even as President Eisenhower exposed the
military-industrial complex he also
expressed a very American deeply felt
desire for peace and Justice that
history has largely forgotten from the
Earth
and that in the goodness of time
All Peoples will come to live together
in a peace guaranteed
by The Binding force of mutual respect
and love
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]